to shift gears a little bit before we
get back to covet stuff as we discussed
many times during the presidency of
donald trump
the humiliating and cartoonish nature of
trump led to many of our historical
allies being distanced from the united
states
uh canada france germany others the us
was increasingly not a part of major
global discussions on important issues
climate of course being
one of them why on earth would a
trump-led united states
be part of climate discussions when
trump said climate change was a hoax
created by the chinese allies talked to
each other
but they increasingly did not involve
trump and the united states
and the reputation of the u.s was in the
toilet a toilet that trump was flushing
10 to 15 times remember that
our reputation was in the toilet and
exactly as predicted
the reputation of the u.s is coming back
quite quickly
i got a lot of phone calls during the
transition period from trump to biden
saying do you think we will recover our
reputation quickly and i said
i think we will because much of the
world is eager
for a non-cartoonish president and the
u.s popularity has improved
significantly in several countries since
joe biden took office
this is data from the latest morning
consult poll looking at the list of
countries
our standing abroad has increased
dramatically
in germany where our favorability has
almost doubled from 24 to 46 percent
germany is followed by japan and france
where our favorability has gone from 36
to 55
and 29 to 46 respectively now to be
clear
these are not exactly stellar numbers
despite major improvements
37 of germans 22 of japanese 29
of french see the us negatively never
mind other countries like canada
47 of canadians see the united states
negatively but the point is what is
happening in the real world
actually does get paid attention to and
it has an
impact abroad it's not a capricious
negativity about the united states trump
out and favorability
increases significantly now anecdotally
americans are also less stressed
day-to-day
because the president the former
president uh
was always at risk of making some
horrifying blunder and unleashing global
shame and embarrassment upon us
we no longer worry about that as
important as it is to realize
that our reputation does respond very
directly to who is the president and to
what the president is doing
it's also important to realize that this
could happen again
most republicans still like trump most
republicans still believe trump won in
november if you can believe that
and most republicans would vote trump
back today if given the chance
despite the successes of joe biden in
his first hundred days vaccination
covet stimulus rehabilitating to some
degree the global reputation of the
country
i'm hearing from friends and relatives
in a variety of countries including
france belgium
argentina where i was born israel it's
primarily a feeling of relief that trump
is gone
and relief gets you part of the way but
it doesn't get you all of the way back
to a recovery in reputation
sadly most of the world understands
what in this country nearly half of
americans don't understand
which is it's objectively bad for us and
everyone else
to elect an incompetent buffoon like
donald trump it really shouldn't be done
again
but it might be if they get a say
and if they're able to suppress the vote
enough in 2024 remember
they didn't suppress it enough in 2020
they tried
but they failed if they succeed at voter
suppression
to a greater degree in 2024 trump could
be back or someone like him now lastly
just because joe biden is restoring our
reputation to some degree
and doing good things doesn't mean bad
things don't still happen
they do and we have to keep paying
attention which is exactly what we're
doing
in a sense boring politics is good but
it can lead to complacency as a result
and
that is exactly how donald trump ended
up coming to power nah he has no shot at
the republican primary oh he won the
republican
primary well there's no way that he can
beat hillary i don't even know if i'll
vote
because it's just not going to be
necessary to uh um
defeat donald trump oh trump beat
hillary well then
what boring should not mean
we don't pay attention but it's okay for
it to mean
less constant stress about which rights
is the president trying to take away
from people
or media or from whomever we are going
to continue following the reputation
of the united states around the world
much improved
in many countries but nowhere near where
we should want to be
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter
at d pacman and boy do we have a good
show for you today i act i think we
should actually
record and keep today's show which is
not what we always do
because today's is actually a pretty
good one